bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat cet après midi à les
sénateurs poursuivent en séance publique
l'examen du projet de loi sur la
transparence de la vie publique
ils ont repris leurs travaux ce matin
après deux jours d'interruption de
séance il faut dire que mardi les
sénateurs radicaux de gauche ont fait
d'adopter une motion de renvoi en
commission de ce texte qui est pourtant
est la réponse du gouvernement à la
sphère cahuzac et hier les sénateurs en
commission sont revenus à la version
initiale du gouvernement qui prévoit la
publication du patrimoine des élus au
journal officiel
alors cette disposition va-t-elle passer
l'épreuve de la séance publique pour le
savoir tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle bonne science à tous nous
reprenons chers collègues la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi organique
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
relatif à la transparence de la vie
publique dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus aux avis de la
commission et du gouvernement sur les
amendements en discussion commune au
sein de l'article 1er et je donne la
parole à monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vais vous donner l'avis de
la commission sur les 103 amendements
compte tenu du fait que comme il y à des
amendements de réécriture de parties
entières de l'article 6 et réécritures
été adoptée ça ferait tomber un certain
nombre d'amendements
néanmoins je dois vous donner les 303
avis car on ne peut pas préjuger
évidemment du vote que vous allez et m
donc eux on nous commençons monsieur le
président comme vous l'avez souhaité par
l'amendement numéro 104 cet amendement
de monsieur comment l'amendement numéro
44 excusez-moi de monsieur longuet et
supprime l'obligation d'envoi des
déclarations de patrimoine à la haute
autorité
ce qu'il empêche pas d'exercer son
contrôle en renvoyant cette mission
bureau des assemblées
le projet de loi organique est bâti
autour d'un équilibre puisque une
autorité extérieure contrôle ce qui
évite tout suspicion de colis de
collusion et ce qui maintient le pouvoir
disciplinaire au bureau des assemblées
évidemment donc et d'autre part je
précise bien pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté que la haute autorité ne
disposerait pas d'un pouvoir
d'injonction à l'égard des
parlementaires
ce n'est pas prévu par la loi la vie et
donc des fagots oui monsieur le
président à jeu j'enchaîne oui bien sûr
l'amendement numéro 78
comme je les dépose et j'y suis
forcément comme je les consignes et mais
il a été brillamment défendu par alain
anziani
comme je les consignes et j'y suis bien
entendu favorables cet amendement
heureux reprend l'ensemble de l'acquis
du travail de la commission
donc tous les amendements qui ont été
adoptées par la commission
quel que soit le groupe qui les ait
présentées ou qui les a présentés de
manière à avoir une vision globale et
peut-être de permettre d'accélérer les
débats
donc je suis bien entendu pour ce qui
est de la menthe du sous-amendement
numéro 131
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
à un amendement similaire puisque les
amendements ont été mes chers collègues
transformer en sous-amendement cet
amendement similaire prévoyait que les
déclarations d'intérêts d'activités des
parlementaires n'étaient plus adressée à
la haute autorité pour les raisons déjà
exprimé l'avis de la commission est
défavorable pour le sous-amendement
numéro e 127 de monsieur longuet qui
consiste à supprimer les mots le cas
échéant eux et bien eux la vie est
également défavorable puisque ces mots
figure dans ledroit actes
elle pour ce qui est du sous-amendement
numéro 132 de monsieur longuet qui après
les mots le mot intérêts et vise à
préciser qu'il s'agit des intérêts
matériels et personnels
c'est un moment de clarification et la
commission y est favorable monsieur
longuet est également resté calme
toutefois bien alors sur le
sous-amendement numéro 139 de monsieur
longuet il est contraire à la logique du
texte la commission a donc émis un avis
défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 176 de madame à ça si la
commission a écarté un amendement
similaire
considérant qu'il n'était pas
raisonnable de faire une nouvelle
déclaration de patrimoine
à chaque session parlementaire madame
assassi puisque vous arriver je me
permets de d'abord de saluer votre
présence et de dire qu il me paraîtrait
un peu lourd je tourne aussi vers
l'ensemble de nos collègues
madame procas ya que vous soyez dans
l'obligation de faire une déclaration au
début de chaque session parlementaire
ça fait beaucoup de déclarations donc
dans un souci de simplification
nous avons sollicité auprès de la dame à
ça si le retrait
sinon nous serons contraint d'émettre un
avis défavorable pour ce qui est du
souss amendement numéro 171 de monsieur
que l'on bat la commission a déjà écarté
à plusieurs reprises un amendement eux
similaires qui seraient eux 13 intrusif
dans la vie privée des proches du
parlementaire puisque vous prévoyez
monsieur que l'on bat que l'on doive
déclarer les biens propres du conjoint
du partenaire lié par un pacs ou du
concubin et ce n'est pas le point de vue
de la commission et ses trucs comprendre
monsieur longuet que ce n'était pas non
plus votre point de vue
oui alors donc c'est un amendement de
provocation pour vous mais je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit le cas pour monsieur
colombes a en tout cas il s'en
expliquera pour ce qui est de la
mandoune sous-amendement numéro 133 de
monsieur longuet la commission a émis un
avis défavorable à un amendement
similaire
les deux catégories des biens mobiliers
et des autres biens figurent déjà
aujourd'hui dans les rubriques de la
déclaration de situation patrimoniale en
vertu du décret du 1er septembre 96
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué monsieur
longuet seul adam va dans le sens de
ceux de boue souhaité que la commission
a prévu qu'il y ait une valeur minimale
pour les biens mobiliers a déclaré
fixées par voie réglementaire du
sous-amendement numéro 134 de monsieur
longuet la commission a demandé le
retrait d'un amendement similaire car il
est satisfait par l'amendement numéro 81
rectifier que j'ai déposée et qui
prévoit un décret en conseil d'état pour
préciser les modalités d'application des
articles relatifs aux déclarations de
sorte que les mots par voie
réglementaire renverront à ce décret en
conseil d'état
et je pense que vous accepterez
peut-être monsieur longuet de retirer
cet amendement qui en quelque sorte est
satisfait sinon vous serez contraint de
donner un avis défavorable pour ce qui
est de la maman 172 de monsieur colombes
à la commission a tranché sur la mention
des fonctions bénévoles en les
maintenant
mais toutefois en précisant les choses
par un sous-amendement numéro 136 dont
nous parlerons dans quelques instants
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 135 de
monsieur y est
la vie est logiquement défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 136 de
monsieur longuet et de monsieur y est
j'ai mais au nom de la commission un
avis favorable monsieur longuet puisque
vous avez bien voulu préciser
qu'il s'agissait en l'espèce uniquement
des fonctions bénévoles exercé à la date
de l'élection faisant naître un conflit
d'intérêt et bien cela est une très
bonne rédaction à notre sens puisque on
prend en compte les fonctions du et
bénévoles qui pourront faire naître un
conflit d'intérêts mais il sera inutile
bien entendu de déclarer les autres
fonctions bénévoles du sous-amendement
numéro 100 soit 128 de monsieur longuet
eux
nous avons insisté sur le fait qu' il
fallait mentionner les activités
professionnelles des personnes
concernées mais n'ont pas le renom
la commission est donc défavorable à cet
amendement
pour ce qui est du sous-amendement e
numéro 178 de monsieur colombes à la
commission a déjà écarté un amendement
du maire de même nature pour deux
raisons premièrement la déclaration
d'intérêts doit être déposé en début de
mandat seulement et de sorte qu'elle ne
peut pas récapituler la participation à
des colloques en cours de mandat
deuxièmement le problème relève du
contrôle interne des assemblées je
précise pour ce qu'ils n'ont pas compris
que monsieur coulombe a proposé qu'en
début de mandat ont déclaré les
colloques auxquels on pourrait
participer au cours du mandat ce qui
paraît difficile madame la ministre bien
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 140
l'avis est défavorable par cohérence
avec ce que j'ai précédemment
il en va de même pour l'amendement
numéro 138 de monsieur longuet
l'amendement numéro 160 le
sous-amendement numéro 164 de madame les
pièces n'a pas été défendu l'amendement
numéro 174 2 e monsieur e collombat
donne lieu à un avis défavorable qui est
totalement homothétique avec celui qui a
été émis précédemment pour les colloques
puisque vous voudriez que l'on déclare
les voyages qui seront accomplies durant
le mandat dès le début du mandat ce qui
apparaît
difficile qui est 2e l'amendement au
numéro 129 de monsieur longuet il m'a
beaucoup surpris puisque monsieur
longuet vous proposer de supprimer le
terme gratification non mais je voulais
simplement vous signaler que ce terme
gratification a été introduit dans la
loi dans le projet de loi par eu un
amendement tout à fait judicieux du
groupe ump de l'assemblée nationale et
notamment de monsieur jean pierre decool
député
donc nous nous avait tous sommes très
attentifs à l'ensemble des travaux de
l'assemblée et que nous regardons avec
intérêt et bienveillance les amendements
d'où qu'ils viennent
donc je pense que vous pourrez peut-être
eu considérer que nous avons quelques
raisons d'émettre un avis défavorable
voilà je vous en remercie pour ce qui
est de l'amendement 130 l'insoumise la
commission qui vise à rectifier le
quantum de peine en cas d'absence de
déclaration de déclarations mensongères
la commission a souhaité conserver les
quantum de peine prévus par le texte
initial la vie et donc défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 141 de
monsieur longuet monsieur longuet
proposent eux une restriction de la
peine complémentaire d'interdiction des
droits civils civiques civils et de
famille en cas de déclaration mensongère
ou délibérément incomplètes à certaines
seulement de ses composantes telles
qu'elles sont définies par l'article 100
331 26 du code pénal pour ne conserver
que celles qui ont un rapport avec
l'activité politique
alors monsieur longuet la commission
donnera un avis favorable à cet
amendement qui est tout à fait judicieux
en vous demandant toutefois si vous
étiez sous l'acceptiez une rectification
qui consisterait à supprimer la
mention temporaire c'est à dire que
l'amendement deviendrait le
sous-amendement deviendrai peuvent être
prononcées à titre complémentaire
l'interdiction d'éligibilité puisque en
l'espèce toute peine est forcément
temporaire voilà donc sous réserve de
cette rectification l'avis de la
commission sera favorable pour ce qui
est de votre amendement au numéro 148
par cohérence
la commission est défavorable pour ce
qui est de l'amendement numéro 185e la
du sous-amendement numéro e
185 la commission n'a pas été saisie
jusqu'à présent de l'idée proposée par
ce sous amendement qui a été déposée à
12 heures qui a été distribué à 12h30
comment vous vous en être excusé et
banham procas ya madame procas ya vos
excuses sont très volontiers accepté
alors la notion de ce sous amendement
aurait pour effet d'empêcher toute
publication des déclarations de
sénateurs d'ici à octobre 2004 14
ce qu'ils ne paraîtraient pas cohérent
avec l'esprit du texte et avec le
principe de la transparence puisque les
déclarations resterait caché pendant un
an
d'autre part cet amendement 7,7 ce
sous-amendement reprend l'idée qui a été
adopté par la commission devrait voir le
dépôt des nouvelles déclarations par les
parlementaires suite au vote de la
présente loi
six mois après la mise en place la haute
autorité
ce délai de six mois auquel s'ajoutent 4
mois pour le contrôle des déclarations
de patrimoine par la haute autorité
en vertu d'un autre amendement qui a été
intégrée dans le texte ou qui le sera je
fais en sorte que les déclarations
seraient publiés nécessairement et dans
tous les cas de figure à la suite des
élections municipales il ne pourrait
donc pas y avoir il ne pourrait donc pas
y avoir d'interférence
donc l'avis est défavorable la vie est
également défavorable par cohérence pour
le souza pour l'amendement numéro 51 de
monsieur longuet pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 65 de madame assassi
qui prévoit une actualisation des
déclarations au début de chaque session
parlementaire
je vous rappelle madame assassi que la
loi prévoit déjà et que le projet de loi
confirme que eux
une déclaration sera toujours nécessaire
en cas de modification substantielle du
patrimoine c'est pourquoi il n'est pas
apparu nécessaire à votre commission de
solliciter le dépôt d'une déclaration de
patrimoine lors de chaque session
ordinaire à la suite de quoi nous avons
souhaité vous demander le retrait et
faute de retrait nous serons contraints
à notre grand regret d'être défavorable
pour ce qui est oui mais c'est le même
amendement madame assassi donc ça ne
compte que pour 1
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
50 2 de monsieur longuet il vise à
réduire le quantum des peines et parents
parallélisme totale avec ce que j'ai
expliqué pour un amendement précédent
la commission y est défavorable de même
qu'elle est défavorable à l'amendement
51 de monsieur longuet par cohérence
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 65 de
madame à ça si il y aura là même le même
avis de la commission vu que c'est le
même amendement pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 52 de monsieur longuet il
propose de réduire le montant des peines
encourues telle que prévue par le texte
pour les mêmes raisons que j'ai expliqué
précédemment
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
105 de monsieur collombat nous tenons a
insisté
e à la commission nous avons insisté sur
le caractère tout à fait pertinent et
utile de cet amendement puisque monsieur
collombat nous permet nous nous propose
d'insérer l'adverbe sciemment et il est
tout à fait clair que il faut en
l'espèce qu'il s'agit d'une volonté
d'une intention manifeste donc cet
amendement est tout à fait judicieux et
gb un avis favorable au nom de la
commission
pour ceux qui en revanche de
l'amendement numéro 99 de monsieur
colombes à eux nous avons toujours la
même logique par rapport aux biens
propres aux conjoints et par conséquent
notre avis est défavorable de
l'amendement numéro 53 de monsieur e
longuet dans la logique et la cohérence
du texte nous sommes contraints de
d'émettre un avis défavorable
l'amendement au numéro 46 de monsieur
longuet relève de son humour qui est
bien connue et que je tiens à saluer il
n'est pas il n'est pas apparu nécessaire
d'ajouter le haut ou aux automobiles et
aux avions mon cher collègue les
bicyclettes car nous ne voulons pas non
plus porter atteinte aux autres modes de
déplacement par exemple les les ballons
aériens
les trottinettes c'est les ulm et les
tricycles donc nous avons pensé que le
texte était suffisant en l'état et
l'avis de la commission et j'en suis
très désolé pour vos monsieur longuet
était favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement de monsieur doligé numéro
monsieur doligé propose d'ajouter
l'expression notamment les oeuvres d'art
mais il va de soi mes chers collègues
que les oeuvres d'art sont comprises
dans les biens mobiliers donc 7,7 ce
tableau 7e
cet amendement est satisfait il est
satisfait parce que ce sont des biens
mobiliers
alors naturellement monsieur longuet on
peut discuter de la valeur des tableaux
qui
allemands qui sont aux belges anglais et
même flamand mêmes flamand voilà
monsieur café m'a précédé dans cette
danse est remarque donc notre avis est
défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 54 de monsieur
longuet l'avis est défavorable puisque
vous proposer de supprimer les
gratifications et que c'est toujours
contraire à l'excellente amendement qui
a été adopté par nos collègues de l'ump
à l'assemblée nationale voilà b vous
demanderez à monsieur decool député ump
qui certainement vous éclairera pour ce
qui est de l'amendement numéro 55 de
monsieur longuet
cet amendement supprime une information
particulièrement utile pour veiller à
empêcher les conflits d'intérêts l'avis
de la commission est défavorable pour ce
qui est de l'amendement numéro 5 de
madame goulet la commission a déjà émis
un avis défavorable et je suis au regret
de devoir le confirmer de l'amendement
numéro 56 de monsieur longuet même avis
que sur l'amendement 55 défavorable
l'amendement numéro 125 de monsieur de
montgolfier même s'il pouvait apparaître
à priori comme une bonne idée
la commission l'a écarté considérant
qu'il pouvait être une source de
contournement de l'obligation d'aider
des déclarations d'intérêt donc l'avis
de la commission était défavorable de
même le par cohérence pour l'amendement
57 de monsieur longuet la vie est le
même que pour l'amendement 55 c'est
parfaitement logique de même pour
l'amendement numéro 6 de madame le
goulet dès lors que l'on ne prend pas en
compte ce qui concerne les biens propres
aux conjoints concubins et personnes
ayant conclu un
pacs dans la logique même de ce choix
nous ne pouvons malheureusement pas
l'adopter
s'agissant de l'amendement numéro 58 de
monsieur longuet il est contraire à ce
qu'avait décidé la commission mais
recouvre partiellement une de ses
préoccupations
donc nous sollicitons le retrait de cet
amendement au bénéfice de l'amendement
sens qui va venir tout à l'heure
s'agissant de l'amendement numéro 100 de
monsieur collombat nous avons souhaité
conserver la mention des fonctions
bénévoles dès lors qu'elles ne seront
mentionné que si elles font naître un
conflit d'intérêts ce pour quoi nous
émettons un avis défavorable
en revanche pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 101 de monsieur
collomb bas auquel j'ai fait allusion
tout à l'heure en m'adressant à monsieur
longuet un amendement similaire a déjà
reçu un avis favorable car la
disposition qui est supprimée créer de
l'imprécision eu cet amendement est
satisfait par l'amendement numéro 78 que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présenter mais au
cas où l'amendement ou plutôt de signer
que monsieur ziani a présenté dans
l'hypothèse où l'amendement numéro 78 ne
serait pas adopté
l'avis de la commission seraient
favorables monsieur collombat pour ce
qui est de l'amendement numéro 102 de
monsieur colombes à eux nous avons
souscrit à ce qui est demandé puisque il
n'est pas apparu à la commission utile
de solliciter la déclaration des mandats
électifs
étant donné que ceux ci ont un caractère
public
par conséquent je donne un avis
favorable à l'amendement numéro 102 pour
ce qui est de l'amendement numéro 59 de
monsieur longuet par cohérence avec les
exposés précédent l'avis de la
commission est défavorable l'amendement
numéro 13 de monsieur anziani supprime
le nom des collaborateurs parlementaires
des déclarations d'intérêt en ne donnant
qu'une seule information leur éventuel
autre activité professionnelle
cela m'apparaît est apparu à la
commission particulièrement judicieux
parce qu' il a pu arriver
je le dis ici que certains
collaborateurs parlementaires soient
partis principalement rémunéré par une
entreprise d'un secteur dont il peut
être question
voilà voilà
c'est pourquoi nommer d'accord monsieur
longuet je prends en compte ce que vous
dites c'est pourquoi il est apparu
judicieux de déclarer les activités
professionnelles des collaborateurs
parlementaires quelle qu'elle soit donc
l'avis est favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 2 de madame e goulet
nous avons considéré que le contrôle des
cadeaux ou avantages reçus par léman
parlementaire relève de la compétence
des bureaux des assemblées ceux ci ont
d'ailleurs statut et ont fixé des seuils
des conditions par conséquent la vi e de
la commission à l'amendement numéro 2 de
madame boulet est favorable pour ce qui
est de l'amendement numéro 14 de
monsieur anziani
il est satisfait par l'amendement 78
dans l'hypothèse où l'amendement 60,18
ne serait pas adopté la vie serait
favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro numéro 60 de
monsieur longuet même chose monsieur
longuet cet amendement donne eu un avis
favorable
dès lors naturellement que la mouvement
numéro 78 ne serait pas adopté ce qui le
ferait tomber
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
103 de monsieur mézard je redis qu'il
n'est pas possible que la déclaration eu
d'intérêt comporte la liste des voyages
effectués dès lors qu'elle est
déposé au début du mandat donc c'est un
demande de retrait sinon un avis
défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 115 de monsieur collombat
en cohérence avec l'amendement précédent
avec la vie sur le monde ment aux
précédents l'avis est défavorable
l'amendement 97 de monsieur le comte n'a
pas été défendu l'amendement numéro 61
de monsieur longuet donne lieu à une
demande de retrait sinon un avis
défavorable dans la cohérence des avis
précédents l'amendement numéro 25 de
madame les pièces n'a pas été défendu
l'amendement 47 de monsieur mort et
précise que les déclarations de
patrimoine seront rendus publics et
publiée au journal officiel
la commission a donné un avis favorable
à cet amendement de monsieur mort et e
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 15 de
monsieur anziani c'est un débat que nous
avons eu longuement la question était de
savoir si en cas dans le cas où nous
restons dans le dispositif de
l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire dans
le cas où les déclarations de patrimoine
peuvent être consultables dans les
préfectures
si cette consultation doivent être
réservées aux électeurs ou à toute
personne âgée de plus de 18 ans la
commission a retenu le la mention des
électeurs c'est pourquoi monsieur asia
ni je donne un avis défavorable à votre
amendement au nom de la commission
pour ce qui est de l'amendement de
madame à ça si c'est numéro 66 cet
amendement n'a pas été retenu par la
commission
je dois donner un avis défavorable c'est
exactement le même sujet e
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro 1
de madame boulet il a déjà été adopté au
stade du texte de la commission
il est satisfait par l'amendement numéro
78 si l'amendement 78 n'était pas adopté
je donnerai un avis favorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
16 de madame tasca il a déjà été adopté
par la commission
il consiste d'inscrire dans la loi et
cela figure dans plusieurs amendements
que vous avez présenté ma chère collègue
l'organe de déontologie parlementaire
la commission y est tout à fait
favorable c'est peu madame le tas ce cas
si vous voulez préciser les choses
oui je vous souhaite rien préciser parce
que je t'ai vu la précision monsieur
longuet en présentant le deuxième
amendement
en fait les saisines par les citoyens
risquent d'être surabondante et donc
nous faisons confiance et le choix de la
commission à la haute autorité pour
opérer une sélection alors que comme
vous l'avez remarqué lorsqu'il s'agira
de signaler les manquements aux
obligations concernant les déclarations
la haute autorité transmettra sens sans
trier merci même peut-être cas continuez
monsieur le président oui pour ce qui
est de cet amendement numéro 16 s'est
donc peu suite à la précision apportée
par madame place qu'à la commission y
est favorable
e pour l'amendement numéro 69 pour des
raisons de commodité nous sollicitons le
retrait madame à ça si toutefois je veux
bien me remettre à la sagesse de la
commission à la sagesse de l'assemblée
mais la difficulté la difficulté c'est
que ça risque d'être une contrainte pour
la haute autorité que de devoir répondre
à toutes les lettres y compris les
lettres d'injures qu'elle pourra
recevoir
pour ce qui est pour ce qui est
mais je me suis prêt après le débat que
nous avons eu en commission à me
remettre à la sagesse de l'assemblée
pour ce qui est de la de l'amendement
numéro 17 de monsieur han jia ni il est
satisfait par l'amendement 78 toutefois
au cas où l'amendement 78 ne serait pas
adopté la vie serait totalement
favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement de monsieur mort et numéro
il propose de supprimer toute publicité
pour les déclarations de situation
patrimoniale des parlementaires tout en
prévoyant la publication au journal
officiel d'un rapport spécial par la
haute autorité lorsque celle ci constate
une évolution inexpliquée du patrimoine
alors cet amendement pour avoir pour
effet naturellement d'entraîner
l'embauchent d'un nombre de membres du
personnel très élevé pour la haute
autorité puisque si la haute autorité
doit calculer pour chaque parlementaire
l'évolution du patrimoine dans tous ses
éléments
ce sera extrêmement complexe en revanche
monsieur longuet il est très clair que
dès lors qu'il y à un dépôt sous la
responsabilité du parlementaire de la
déclaration dans les formes prévues par
la loi au début du mandat à la fin du
mandat
cela nous paraît suffire d'autant plus
d'autant plus que d'autant plus que
monsieur oui vous êtes je ne suis pas
maoïste monsieur longuet déjà dit j'ai
déjà dit ce matin à monsieur cambon qui
nous a d'ailleurs quitté je le regrette
lui va revenir
bon alors donc je rappelle en outre que
mon cher collègue chaque fois qu'il est
d'évolution substantielle du patrimoine
nous sommes d'ores et déjà tenus de le
déclarer et cela est confirmé par le
présent projet de loi
s'agissant de l'amendement numéro 124 de
monsieur e mézard il supprime toute
publicité pour les déclarations de
situation patrimoniale
il est contraire à la position de la
commission la vie et donc défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
106 de monsieur colombes à eux ils
l'avis est défavorable pour la même
raison
pour ce qui est de l'amendement eu 48 de
monsieur mort et il propose de publier
les appréciations portées par la haute
autorité sur les déclarations de
situation patrimoniale des
parlementaires sans prévoir la publicité
de ces déclarations alors c'est un
amendement très paradoxal parce que
berry mon cher collègue on pourrait
publier les critiques que la haute
autorité fait à une déclaration sans
publier les déclarations vous voyez bien
quand nous lisons les rapports de la
cour des comptes il ya ce que pense à
cour des comptes mais il ya aussi ce
qu'a déclaré la personne morale qui est
en cause et aussi les réponses qu'elle a
fait
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'avis est défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 62
monsieur longuet l'avis est défavorable
puisque eux c'est contraire à la
position de la commission
il en va de même pour l'amendement 104
de monsieur collombat alors maintenant
j'arrive à l'amendement numéro un
soixante dix neuf que j'ai l'honneur de
cosigner et qui a été présentée tout à
l'heure par monsieur anziani
cet amendement est très important
puisque madame la ministre
il propose de revenir au texte du projet
de loi du gouvernement
je pense donc il sera accueilli de
bonnes manières par le gouvernement mes
chers collègues je redis je reviens en
quelques mots sur ce sujet parce que
c'est sans doute le sujet le plus
important de ce débat de cet après midi
nous avons émis un désaccord assez
profonds avec ce qu'a voté l'assemblée
nationale c'est à dire le fait que les
déclarations de patrimoine pourrait être
universellement conçu
tu es en préfecture puisque tout
électeur 45 millions d'électeurs
pourront les consulter et il nous paraît
très difficile non non on est resté on
est resté aux électeurs monsieur longuet
non mais j'ai donné un avis défavorable
monsieur longer monsieur longuet vous
n'avez pas suivi
donc à partir du moment où une
ces déclarations peuvent être
universellement consultables ou très
largement par des dizaines de millions
de personnes
il nous paraît très paradoxal que leur
communication ou leurs publications
donnent lieu à un an de prison ce qui
n'est pas rien madame la ministre est à
45000 euros d'amendé
donc dans un premier temps la commission
a décidé de supprimer l'infraction et la
sanction
c'est ce que nous avions décidé dans le
texte approuvé avant qu'il y ait le
renvoi en commission
nous sommes revenus là dessus et comme
je les dis en commission il y a eu un
surcroît de réflexion ce surcroît de
réflexion nous a conduit à considérer
que dès lors qu'il n'y avait plus
d'infractions ni de sanction bien
entendu la communication était possible
licité normale à partir de ce moment là
mieux vaut dire que les déclarations de
patrimoine des parlementaires sont
publiés comme le sont celles des
ministres c'est le sens de cet
amendement numéro 79 qui est toutefois
assortie d'un second alinéa auquel nous
tenons beaucoup et qui sanctionne eux
d'une amende de 7500 euros
les communications ou publications
mensongères ou délibérément inexact
c'est à dire que nous considérons qu'il
est logique qu'il puisse y avoir
publicis
t pour les parlementaires comme pour les
ministres mais que en cas de publication
visant à porter atteinte à la personne
de même que en cas de diffamation eh
bien il y est évidemment une sanction
c'est pourquoi la commission a émis un
avis favorable à cet amendement
79 pour ce qui est du sous amendement
182 monsieur colombes à eux
la commission a déjà écarté un
amendement similaire qui repose sur le
principe de l'absence de publicité des
déclarations
c'est donc strictement contraires à ce
que l amendement dont je viens de parler
donc l'avis est défavorable
pour ce qui est du sous-amendement de
monsieur longuet numéro 143
c'était un avis défavorable exactement
pour la même raison
en fait il y a deux positions soit on
est partisan de la publication des
déclarations seront pense qu'il ne faut
pas qu'elle soit publiée et d'ailleurs
autant dire que le débat dans cet
hémicycle
il est entre ces deux positions qui
peuvent être tout à fait clairement
exprimée et défendu l'amendement numéro
122 de monsieur zocchetto et signée par
plusieurs de nos collègues et notamment
madame boulet ici présente cet
amendement est strictement identique à
l'amendement de la commission
c'est à dire qu'il prévoit la
publication dans le journal officiel et
une sanction en cas de publication
fallacieuse mensongère délibérément
inexactes je suis bien sûr favorable à
cet amendement identique à celui qui a
été précédemment présentés pour ce qui
est de l'amendement 98 il s'agit d'un
amendement de repli pour le cas où les
amendements précédent n'aurait pas ne
serait pas adopté
dans ce cas nous reviendrons au
dispositif que nous avions adopté
d'abord qui consisterait à supprimer
toute infraction et toute sanction en
cas de communication dès lors que l'on
communiquerait et on communiquera
quelque chose d'universel mans
consultables la mode le sous-amendement
155 de madame les pièces n'est pas
défendu pour ce qui est de la bande du
sous-amendement 142 2 e
monsieur longuet il s'agit d'un rôle de
l'existence d'un registre alors la
commission n'est pas favorable à ce que
dans le cas où il y aurait consultation
auprès des préfectures
il y est un registre des gens qui
seraient venus consulter ou bien on a le
droit de venir consulter dès lors qu'on
est électeur les agents de la préfecture
peuvent demander la carte d'électeur
dans ce cas là mais nous ne pensons pas
qu'il faut mentionner toutes les
personnes après se posera la question de
savoir qui peut consulter le registre et
cetera nous avons un amendement 162 de
madame les pièces qui n'a pas été
défendu le l'amendement ce le
sous-amendement 144 de monsieur longuet
est contraire à la position de la
commission le l'amendement 18 de
monsieur 11 ya ni donné un avis
défavorable dans les mêmes conditions
que l'amendement précédent l'amendement
36 de madame li pièce n'est pas défendu
l'amendement 12,2 madame de roche donné
un avis défavorable car au contraire peu
pour les mêmes raisons que la vie a été
défavorable sur l'amendement de monsieur
longuet pour ce qui est de l'amendement
numéro 3 de madame goulet eux ce sera
une demande de retrait
ou alors un avis défavorable par
cohérence la vie sera le même sur
l'amendement numéro 4 de madame boulet
pour l'amendement numéro 70 comme je lé
fais tout à l'heure je demanderai leur
retrait mais sinon suite au débat j fait
référence explicitement cumulée à la
commission je m'entretiendrai à la
sagesse je m'en remettrai la sagesse du
sénat
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
19 de monsieur ancien nid
cet amendement supprime les sanctions
pénales en cas de divulgation des
informations au sein des déclarations de
situation de patrimoine il correspond à
la position de l'aco la commission avait
adopté dans un premier temps il est
satisfait par l'amendement 79 mais aucun
amendement 79 ne serait pas adopté
votre amendement eux donneraient lieu à
un avis favorable mon cher collègue
pour ce qui est de l'amendement eu 67 de
madame à ça si cet amendement supprime
les sanctions pénales en cas de
divulgation des informations au sein
déclaration de situation de patrimoine
là la position de la commission est
favorable à cet amendement
sous réserve d'une légères modifications
pour le rendre identique à l'amendement
numéro 19
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
68 de madame assassi dans les mêmes
conditions l'avis est favorable pour ce
qui est de l'amendement 80 présentée par
monsieur anziani
cet amendement eux comme les précédents
reprend l'ensemble des amendements
d'où qu'il vienne de quelque groupe que
ce soit qui ont été adoptées par la
commission lors de la l'examen précédent
bien entendu la commission y est
favorable
par cohérence nous sommes contraints
d'être défavorable à l'amendement 149 de
monsieur longuet ainsi d'ailleurs qu'à
l'amendement numéro 175 de monsieur
colombes à l'amendement 179 de madame
assassi qui vise remplacer le mot
électeurs par le mot citoyen recevra
forcément le même avis défavorable que
l'amendement similaire de monsieur
anziani
pour ce qui est de l'amendement au
numéro 151 de monsieur longuet qui
contraindrait à faire tous les ans de
nouvelles déclarations
dans le souci de la légèreté des
procédures et d'éviter des lourdeurs qui
pourraient être évités
la commission est défavorable pour ce
qui est du sous-amendement 152 de
monsieur longuet il est satisfait les
membres et rapporteur de la haute
autorité sont déjà en vertu du texte lié
par le secret professionnel
donc nous demandons le retrait sinon je
serai contraint d'être défavorable
pour ce qui est de la bande du
sous-amendement 152 monsieur longuet est
bien la vie est également défavorable
pour les mêmes raisons l'amendement pour
scier du sous-amendement 145 de monsieur
longuet il est contraire au à la
position de la commission
oui comment moment le jeu soit 145 oui
alors bon on va continuer ouvert ensuite
j'ai oublié lesquelles monsieur le
président on verra ensuite bon alors
j'arrive à l'amendement numéro e 165 du
gouvernement la commission expressément
prévu un délai de six mois pour que les
parlementaires remplissent les nouvelles
obligations des kills déclaratives qui
résulteraient de ce texte de façon à ce
que leur publication ne risque pas
d'intervenir pendant la campagne des
élections municipales
c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai répondu à
madame pro cassia je lui ai dit qu'on
avait admis mis en place un délai de six
mois qui ajouté aux quatre mois du délai
de contrôle dont dispose la haute
autorité fait qu' il n'y a aucune chance
que cela interfère d'aucune manière que
ce soit avec les prochaines élections
municipales
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demanderons à madame la ministre si elle
veut bien retiré son amendement sinon
nous serons contraints d'y être
défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 20 de monsieur anziani
il précise qu'à l'issue d'un délai d'un
an qui suit la fin du mandat du député
la déclaration de situation patrimoniale
déposé au titre de ce mandat
n'est plus consultable c'est une idée
qui est apparue judicieuse judicieuse à
la commission compte-tenu monsieur
longuet que la haute autorité pourra
continuer à exercer son office donc
l'avis est favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 63 de monsieur longuet qui
est un amendement eu de conséquence e
par parallélisme avec ce que j'ai dit de
l'amande d'un des amendements précédent
je demanderai leur retrait ou à défaut
l'avis de la commission sera défavorable
pour ce qui est de l'amande douce de
l'amendement 126 de monsieur de
montgolfier
en vertu de ce que j'ai dit à propos
d'un amendement précédent l'avis de la
commission est toujours défavorable
il en est de même pour l'amendement de
conséquences 64 de monsieur longuet de
même pour l'amendement 7 de madame e
goulet nous demanderons le retrait ou
seront contraints d'être défavorable
pour l'amendement sans cesse de monsieur
pozzo di borgo
il est contraire à la logique du texte
et à la position de la commission car il
supprime la compétence de la haute
autorité en matière de déclaration
d'intérêts d'activités
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler la
position de la commission est
défavorable et pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 71 de madame assassi
pour les raisons déjà exposé puisque
cela cet amendement aurait pour effet
outre les deux publications du
patrimoine au début les deux
transmissions et publication du
patrimoine en début et fin de mandat
outre le fait que toute modification
substantielle doit être déclarée
d'ajouter un nouveau document rendant
compte de l'évolution du patrimoine de
chaque parlementaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
et j'oubliais et des amendements alors
excusez moi je vous prie d'accepter mes
excuses
donc poussier de l'amendement 177 de
madame eux à sa 6e c'est exactement ce
dont je viens de parler donc le
forcément la position est la même et
pour ce qui est de l'amendement 186 de
monsieur pozzo di borgo
c'est également ce dont je viens de
parler donc la position est la même pour
ce qui est de l'amendement le 117 de
monsieur pozzo di borgo la position est
la même par cohérence eux de même eu
l'amendement 9 de madame boulet est
satisfait puisque eux en cas
d'observation la haute autorité
sollicitera nécessairement le
parlementaire pour lui demander des
explications il est donc satisfait
pour ce qui est de l'amendement numéro
21 de madame tasca qui prévoit
l'information de l'organe de l'instance
il faut rectifier en charge de la
déontologie parlementaire
la commission y est favorable dans la
même logique que celle qui fonde la les
divers amendements que vous avez
présenté à cet égard enfin pour ce qui
est de l'amendement numéro 166 du
gouvernement qui cette fois ci prévoit
de passer de 2 mois à 4 mois que le
commentaire sera le même que pour votre
sous-amendement numéro 165 donc nous
solliciterons le retrait faute de quoi
nous serons contraints d'être
défavorable à votre amendement madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je pense
avoir donné la vie sur l'ensemble des
amendements en regrettant une fois
encore monsieur le président le
caractère un peu complexe de cette
procédure bien je vous remercie monsieur
le président madame la ministre
à votre tour
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
d'abord permettez-moi d'aix de présenter
des excuses d'alain vidalies ce qui n'a
pas pu se joindre à vous cet après midi
et que je remplace en ayant évidemment
veiller à faire le lien avec ce que vous
vous êtes dit ce matin donc d'abord
merci pour toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont présenté leur amendement d'une
façon générale je retiens de ces
derniers que le sénat a donc proposé de
modifier le dispositif s'agissant de la
publication des déclarations de
patrimoine des parlementaires sur ce
sujet le gouvernement s'en remet à la
sagesse de votre haute assemblée et nous
sommes par ailleurs assez sensible à
certains des points qui ont été
soulevées je pense aux points soulevés
par le groupe socialiste s'agissant de
favoriser l'accès en open data des
données publiables par la haute autorité
de transparence je pense aussi un autre
point auquel nous adhérons évidemment
qui est l'impératif de donner une assise
forte aux organes de déontologie des
parlementaires qui était évoqué ce matin
nous sommes aussi sensible aux soucis
delà de cette assemblée d'avoir une
meilleure rédaction des dispositions
pénales comme l'a suggéré monsieur
collomb va par exemple alors s'agissant
maintenant de cette longue discussion
autour de vos amendements je vais
peut-être tout simplement vous faire
connaître les avis favorable ou alors de
sagesse du gouvernement en partant du
principe que ce que je n'évoquerai pas
son nom un avis défavorable de notre
part donc si on considère que certains
des amendements ou des sous-amendements
étaient des amendements ou des
sous-amendements de pure repli je vous
dirais que
nous disons sagesse sur l'amendement 78
de monsieur anziani donc réécrivant
l'article 1er tout comme nous disons
sagesse sur les sous amendement 138 141
de monsieur longuet en as we pardonnez
moi oui je vous en prie alors allez-y
parce que comme le président survient de
les repasser en revue donc je ne
m'attarde pas donc je redis alors
sagesse sur l'amendement 78 donc réécrit
mon article 1er l'amendement présenté
par monsieur anziani sagesse également
sur les sous amendement 138 141 de
monsieur longuet en revanche défavorable
sur les autres sous-amendement je
continue un avis de sagesse aussi la
part du gouvernement sur l'amendement 65
de madame assassi donc sur la mise à
jour annuelle des déclarations un avis
de sagesse sur l'amendement 105 celui
qui explicitent l'intention comme
élément constitutif donc l'amendement
présenté par monsieur collombat léman
constitutif dans l'omission de
déclaration
donc avis de sagesse du gouvernement et
un avis de sagesse aussi sur
l'amendement 13 celui qui était présenté
par monsieur anziani donc sur
l'intégration des activités des
collaborateurs dans la déclaration
d'intérêts des parlementaires je
m'arrête un instant le temps que vous
preniez note ensuite un avis favorable
du gouvernement sur l'amendement numéro
2 de madame rouler celui qui supprime
l'article 38 l'alinéa pardon foot 38 et
un avis favorable aussi sur l'amendement
14 présentée par monsieur en diani donc
sur les cadeaux et avantages avis
favorable aussi pour l'amendement
présenté par monsieur y est l'amendement
numéro 60 sur ce sujet
un avis de sagesse sur l'amendement 15
présentée par monsieur diani en revanche
une demande de retrait du 66 celui qui
était présenté par madame à ça si le
président de la commission a expliqué
pourquoi et nous le rejoignons un avis
favorable sur l'amendement numéro un qui
était présenté par madame goulet dans
lequel elle apportait des précisions sur
les conditions dans lesquelles les
lecteurs peut adresser ses observations
à la haute autorité de transparence donc
favorable à cet amendement numéro un
nous nous prononçons par la sagesse sur
l'amendement numéro 16 présenté par
madame tasca sur sept meilleurs circuits
d'information entre la haute autorité de
transparence d'une part et les organes
de déontologie c'est évidemment une
question qui vous concerne au premier
chef donc sagesse nous sommes je le
disais en introduction favorable à
l'amendement de 17 de monsieur en
dialyse sur l'open data enfin l'accès en
open data des données publiées par la
haute autorité de transparence et nous
sommes donc pour répondre à la question
du monsieur le président sur une
position de sagesse s'agissant de
l'amendement 79 qui a été longuement
présenté par monsieur sur donc le 79
rectifié plus exactement
nous nous prononçons là aussi en termes
de sagesse sur le sous-amendement numéro
122 celui qui était présenté par
monsieur mercier la haute assemblée en
décidera sagesse toujours sur votre
amendement de sueur le 98 sagesse sur
l'amendement de monsieur andia ni le
numéro 18 qui concernait donc
l'extension du droit de consultation à
toute personne de plus de 18 ans nous
sommes favorables le gouvernement est
favorable aux amendements 3 et 4 de
madame boulet favorable à l'amendement
80 rectifié de monsieur sueur qui
réécrit donc l'article 1er
sagesse pour ce qui concerne le
sous-amendement 179 de madame assassi
favorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 20 celui qui organise de
façon un peu précise la fin de la
période de consultation donc il était
présenté par monsieur anziani est
favorable également à l'amendement 21
madame tasca et enfin pour répondre aux
questions qui nous étaient posées par
monsieur le président la commission des
lois le gouvernement est d'accord pour
retirer le sous-amendement 165 sur
l'entrée en vigueur progressive des
obligations déclaratives et du coup la
logique veut que nous retirions
également l'amendement 166 qui portaient
donc sur le même sujet voilà j'espère
que vous avez pu prendre note de tout
cela rien de bien surprenant dans ce que
je viens de dire je crois merci merci
alors sur monsieur le président e
les choses étaient un peu complexe il
est il serait judicieux que l'on puisse
voter d'abord sur les amendements qui
réécrivent l'arctique et qui intègre
comme je les dis des amendements de tous
les groupes qui ont été peu adopté lors
de la première lecture cela aura lieu
naturellement
pour ce qui est du premier de ces
amendements
en revanche monsieur le président je ne
solliciterai la priorité du vote sur les
amendements 79 et 122 de manière à ce
qu'il soit mis au vote avant le 48 dans
la logique que je viens d'expliquer
l'avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
et bien sûr je suis favorable aussi
d'accord bien donc on va commencer par
le 79 le 44 d'abord non par le 44 qui
est celui de monsieur longuet qui a deux
avis défavorables que je vais mettre aux
voix
allez-y en explications de vote
oui mais vous pouvez expliquer votre
votre pension longuet vous l'expliquer
tout de suite par des explications de
vote si l'isi
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs mes chers collègues
voilà cet amendement 44 est une
réécriture de l'article 1er imaginez et
voulu par l'ump et qui rappelle l'
architecture d'ensemble que nous
souhaitons dans cet objectif de
conforter l'image du parlement devant
l'opinion française en général
cette réécriture abouti à faire en sorte
que la commission administrative
désormais intitulé haute autorité soit
compétente en ce qui concerne les
déclarations patrimoniales et
exclusivement en ce qui concerne les
déclarations patrimoniales et que par
ailleurs et par voie de conséquence
puisque elle ne serait plus compétente
en matière de déontologie dont nous
considérons qu'elle doit être sous le
seul contrôle des assemblées et plus
précisément de l'exécutif de ces
assemblées c'est à dire les bureaux nous
dans l' architecture de notre amendement
demandons à ce que les déclarations
d'intérêt soit adressée pour le cas
échéant être évalués par les seuls
bureaux des assemblées alors je
n'entrerai pas dans le détail du
dispositif
je rappelle simplement cette conviction
forte pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
malentendu personne ne sut en génie n'a
peur de quoi que ce soit n'a peur de
quelques déclarations que ce soit la
seule chose dont nous ayons vraiment
peur c'est ce qu'évoquait avec passion
notre collègue pozzo di borgo
c'est d'un parlement qui soit qu'ils
s'autocensurent qui s'affaiblissent lui
même en se plaçant sous l'autorité de
fait et de droit de personnalité certes
éminente et toute leur vie
professionnelle le démontre mais
parfaitement éloigné de l'expérience
parlementaire et dont l'autorité ne
dépend que de l'exécutif
c'est vrai naturellement des magistrats
qui appartiennent à l'ordre judiciaire
mais c'est plus vrai encore du président
de la haute autorité dont le nom est
proposée par le président de la
république nous serions donc le seul
pays où la déontologie des
parlementaires échapperait aux
parlementaires pour appartenir un
organisme de type administrative je
rappelle que à l'occasion du rapport 518
qui a été largement citée qui était
largement oecuméniques la large majorité
des membres de ce groupe d'étude
présidée par jean-jacques hyest et par
vous même chaque collègue anziani avait
conclu à ce que la technologie devait
appartenir à obuts aux exécutifs des
assemblées à travers le dispositif que
vous nous proposez d'adopter on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une double
compétence est en germe chers collègues
daska parce que j'ai bien écouté il y as
en germe une concurrence d'appréciation
de ce que doit être la déontologie au
regard des conflits d'intérêts c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec conviction je
défends cet amendement sans avoir la
certitude que vous l'adoptez cependant
mais il le restera au moins dans nos
travaux collectifs une trace écrite de
la mise en garde que le groupe pour
qu'elles j'appartiens adresse au
gouvernement et à travers le
gouvernement législateur sur le risque
de déposséder une assemblée de la
responsabilité de faire en quelque sorte
le ménage chez elle comme si elle
n'était pas en mesure de le faire quel
paradoxe
nous pouvons voter des lois pour
demander aux français de celle de
d'adopter tel ou tel comportement
mais nous serions incapables d'assurer
nous mêmes la déontologie de notre
comportement quotidien toutes les
professions qui ont des codes
déontologiques les organisent par
eux-mêmes etc les infractions
éventuelles au code de déontologie dès
lors qu'elles revêtent
un cas un caractère délictuel sont
évidemment transférer à l'autorité
judiciaire
notre objectif n'est pas d'épargner aux
parlementaires délinquants ou criminels
la référence à l'autorité judiciaire
notre objectif est dans la vie
quotidienne très simple très immédiates
avec la complexité de notre métier
la possibilité de laisser aux exécutifs
des assemblées leur pleine
responsabilité
merci monsieur longuet monsieur pozzo di
borgo pour explication de vote puis dans
le même sens que j'ai dit ce matin c'est
vrai que nous avons en france par
rapport à d'autres parlements une
diminution grignotage permanent de du
pouvoir des parlementaires a commencé
d'ailleurs que l'article 34 de la
constitution c'était une constitution
qui a été fait en fait pour limiter le
pouvoir des parlementaires même c'est à
équilibrer les choses et ça ne fait que
continuer sur cette affaire l'esprit
cette loi on le retrouve ce grignotage
alors on pourrait dire évidemment que la
haute autorité dans l'esprit de
l'article 40 du code pénal puisqu'elle
ce constat se délient évidemment
prévient le parquet mais moi justement
je me demande en fait si dans tout ça si
la création d'autorités on est pas en
train de créer également une autre
autorité judiciaire
en fait qu'elle va jouer le rôle du
parquet merci a transmis au parquet dire
qu'en fait c'est elle qui va avoir
compétence pour transmettre au parquet
civil et sion alors c'est un peu ambigu
évidemment c'est un peu joué sur les
mots mais moi j'ai tendance à penser que
dans cette affaire mes chers collègues
nous sommes nous les parlementaires en
train de nous flageller nous sommes en
train de diminuer le pouvoir que nous
avons on les français ont besoin d'un
pouvoir exécutif fort
ils ont besoin de justice respectée
forte mais ont besoin aussi d'un
parlement respecter fort et le problème
c'est que le parlement lui-même se
flagellent parlement lui-même diminue
c'est pour pouvoir voilà c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voterai l'amendement de
nos collègues de l'ump
merci mon cher collègue monsieur de
l'est pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
si monsieur café de miel laisser parler
merci chers collègues donc si si nous
étudions ce texte il faut rappeler que
c'est suite à la sphère cahuzac et que
pour moi ce texte ne répond pas aux
problèmes qui sont posés par cette
affaire puisque les déclarations de
patrimoine nous les avions déjà à faire
depuis longtemps et que les problèmes
qui ont été soulevés par cette affaire
cahuzac ne seront pas résolus par les
textes que vous nous proposez que le
gouvernement nous propose donc ça c'est
mon premier point le la deuxième chose
est qui qui qui en découle c'est que je
pense que le diagnostic n'est pas le bon
le diagnostic c'était un renforcement du
contrôle des déclarations parce que
c'est vrai qu'on déclare depuis
longtemps les notre patrimoine
mais les contrôles sont insuffisants moi
je pense qu'il ya un renforcement
nécessaire mais il n'y avait pas besoin
d'aller beaucoup plus loin et je l'ait
pas dit ce matin mais je le dis là pour
moi
ce que l'on devrait proposer c'est un
délit de parjure parce que la sphère
cahuzac a montré qu'il y avait il y
avait une nécessité il y avait un
problème de parjure et que ce délit de
parjure je trouve dommage que le
gouvernement de l'époque proposait en
réaction à cette affaire et sur ce qui
le patrimoine
moi personnellement je suis gêné parce
que j'ai rien à cacher donc ça me gêne
pas de publier mon pape mon patrimoine
simplement je trouve que là on montre du
doigt les élus et les parlementaires et
que finalement son raison est que notre
position est la position et je défendrai
avec hervé maurey qui à écrire des
amendements dont le président sera
finalement les a repoussés sans beaucoup
d'arguments
c'est que la haute autorité 6 6 la haute
autorité veut servir à quelque chose
c'est quand même à contrôler les
évolutions du patrimoine et notamment
les évolutions anormales et l'absence de
justification ou les insuffisances dans
ses déclarations
et là on nous dit mais la haute autorité
ne va pas faire ça parce que sinon elle
va avoir trop de travail la haute
autorité qu'elle va faire elle va
simplement regarder qu'elle a bien reçu
et puis elle va publier dans le journal
officiel
et voilà et qu'est ce qu'elle leur a
servi à quoi donc moi je suis je suis un
peu surpris par cette réponse est là on
où moi je reviens sur l'amendement 44
l'amendement de 44 10 qu'est-ce qu'on
fait la haute autorité va remplacer la
commission avec quelques moyens
supplémentaires pourquoi pas l'appeler
haute autorité il ya un an au conseil
des finances publiques ya plein de au
conseil et autres on peut toujours créer
une haute autorité
elle aura peut-être des moyens renforcés
pour ça mais par contre pour ce qui est
des conflits d'intérêts et des
déclarations d'intérêt que nous faisons
déjà aussi que ces déclarations
d'intérêt continuent à être du ressort
des bureaux des assemblées de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et qu
il ne m'apparaît pas il n'est pas apparu
en tout cas dans les dernières années
qu'il ya eu des manquements à l'action
et au contrôle de ses bureaux à chaque
fois qu'ils ont été saisis je pense
qu'ils se sont prononcés notre bonne
position avec le pluralisme qui chez à
ces instances donc voila moi je serais
pour voter ce cet amendement 1 puisque
il me semble aller dans le bon sens de
ce qui est une amélioration par rapport
aux systèmes existants sont allés trop
loin dans le voyeurisme et dans le
l'étalement des patrimoines de tout le
monde
merci monsieur de l'est madame goulet
oui c'est le président a même miss mes
chers collègues entre eux finalement
l'amendement 44 et le 78 que nous
rectifier bis que nous propose le
rapporteur nous avons deux rédactions et
2 nouvelle rédaction de cet article 1er
et il se trouve que l'article 78 bis
rectifié bis présente un avantage c'est
qu'il
il intègre déjà le travail qu'avait fait
notre commission des lois avant que la
motion de renvoi en commission ne soit
adoptée et donc en réalité l'article 78
de rectifier bis et plus complet
évidemment que l' article que
l'amendement 44 il a aussi une
un autre à notre avantage il ne dénature
pas le texte maintient des obligations
de déclaration hélas la question de la
publication notamment au journal
officiel à l'amendement 122 keith
hackett un amendement qui a été
largement cosigné par un grand nombre
des membres du groupe
udi uc et qui prévoit 1 une publication
au journal officiel alors à 7 à ce stade
de la discussion de choses bon la
commission de transparence a toujours
fait son travail en cas d'évolution du
patrimoine
nous avons pu les uns et les autres et à
titre personnel il ya une succession et
un certain nombre de deux problèmes
immobiliers liés à une succession
ma déclaration de patrimoine tels que je
les ai effectué comme nous l'avons tous
effectué au sein de la commission de
transparence avait connu des
modifications la commission de
transparence à demander des comptes a
entendu à nos terres a demandé toutes
les explications possibles et donc cette
commission de transparence à laquelle
nous sommes tous soumis depuis que nous
sommes élus fait fait très bien son
travail
reste la question de l'opinion publique
et du de la difficulté dans laquelle
nous a misé certain nombre d'affaires
récentes auquel mon collègue notre
collègue de la haye faisait allusion
tout à l'heure et là je crois que la
solution qui consiste à publier au
journal officiel est la solution la plus
claire la plus transparente et de toute
façon qui a une publication ou qui en
est pas un moment ou à un autre vous
savez très bien que la volonté de nos
concitoyens d'aller fouiller dans toutes
les poubelles finiront par nous jouer
des tours
donc moi je crois que au plus simple au
mieux le journal officiel est fait pour
ça donc je voterai par préférence
l'amendement 78 rectifié bis de la
commission auxquelles on ajoutera je
l'espère tout à l'heure l'amendement 122
présenté par françois zocchetto et
michel mercier merci madame boulet
plus d'explications de vote monsieur
collombat sur 7 sur cet amendement
je dois dire que dans un certain sens
l'orientation en matière de publication
ont pris part cet amendement et nous
paraît effectivement confins plus plus
proche de ce que nous souhaitons que ce
qui a été proposé par la commission met
par ailleurs
par ailleurs on constate que dans sa
rédaction mais si je crois que c'est
peut-être le fait des travaux tels
qu'ils ont été mené il ya un certain
nombre de points qui pour nous ne sont
pas ne sont pas acceptables et comité
accepte qu'ils ont été pris en compte
par le rapporteur tout à l'heure
notamment l'élimination de la mention
des mandats électifs et aussi le fait
que tout manquement supposerait à la
déclaration aux obligations de la
déclaration supposerait que cela soit
que la part dont il y ait sciemment une
volonté de tromper donc pour cette pour
cet ensemble de raisons nous nous
obtiendrons sur ceux sur cet amendement
44,11 j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer
sur les 78
mais je voudrais savoir s'agissant donc
de l'amendement 79 comme manger un
amendement 120 kg est pris en sandwich
ceux qui le ce qu'il devient ce qu'il
devient dans cette
dans cette affaire nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat mais nous
reviendrons plus largement sur l'examen
de ce projet de loi sur la transparence
de la vie publique dans le journal de
19h présenté ce soir par marie brimo
très bonne soirée à tous